got a very thematic newscast for you I
think you're going to enjoy this look I
don't think that I'm overstating
tonight's lead when I say there's a
general sense of satisfaction if not
Glee all over the world today with the
news that national security advisor John
Bolton has been fired of course I mean
he resigned wink John Bolton is an
American nationalists who also happens
to be a neoconservative who open who
also happens to be a guy that even Hawks
say is too hawkish even the Hawks call
him hawk hawkish and listen that saying
something with this crowd if you know
nothing about John Bolton know this know
this to this day when more than 90% of
Americans say that the invasion of Iraq
was an unmitigated disaster
which has said our foreign policy back
probably something like 50 years in the
Middle East John Bolton who was one of
those who pushed for the invasion with
lies as we know still thinks it was a
good idea a good thing to invade look if
there is a Bolton doctrine if there's a
Bolton doctrine it goes something like
this
any country in the world that doesn't
agree with the United States
it's economic interest or even its
allies is fodder for regime change and
covert or military intervention and more
often more often than not his policies
have done more harm than good see that's
the problem in the end right and you
know what else has done is caused the
United States our country to be more
hated around the world
you think I'm kidding let's go to the
map come on I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
exactly what I'm talking about I'm gonna
take you through these countries let's
start in Venezuela is there a clearer
example than Venezuela where Bolton has
initiated three count'em coos in
Venezuela he's anointed a new president
and come just short of sending in the
Marines reality check on this one mr.
Bolton he's made venezuelan President
Hugo Chavez more popular and the people
of Venezuela more anti-american than
ever before let's move to Cuba Bolton
has
down on the government of Cuba at a time
when Cuban officials were hoping to
somehow reengage reestablished relations
with the United States reality-check
Cuba and the United States are back on a
cold war footing exactly where they were
60 years ago good let's let's flip the
map a little bit I want to take you to a
couple of other countries let's start
with Libya mr. Bolten actually holds up
Libya as the perfect model for how to
eliminate a government he actually calls
it the Libya model in quotes reality
check the US and NATO's military
intervention in Libya has turned the
country into a hellhole right for
terrorists as are their Dow while
flooding Europe with hundreds of
thousands of refugees Syria Bolton
publicly undermined president Trump's
plans to bring US troops home from Syria
announcing that they had to stay to
counter Iran reality-check an estimated
400,000 people have been killed in Syria
as Bolton's strategy of removing the
Assad quote regime continues with more
refugees flooding into Europe and that
is destabilizing a lot of the European
governments Iran Bolton has publicly
called for war with Iran parroting
Israeli Prime Minister Netanyahu's calls
for an end to the quote Iranian regime
pushing mr. Trump to renege on the nuke
deal and undermining mr. Trump's intense
attempts to meet with Iranian leaders
what's the reality check here Iranian
relations with the United States have
worsened with skirmishes in the Gulf the
Persian Gulf to the point where our own
allies like France and Japan in the last
couple weeks are bypassing the United
States and reaching out to them to the
Iranians when does that happen before
Yemen Bolton has continued to push for
more military involvement with the war
in Yemen believing that we must back the
Saudi royal family at all cost and
saying that quote listen to this this is
a direct quote that part of the world
would be a mess if we leave reality
check mr. Bolton that
part of the world is already a bloody
mess fifty thousand children are dead in
large measure because we're there North
Korea Bolton has repeatedly disagreed
with President Trump on his
rapprochement with North Korea and has
threatened to attack North Korea for
violating US sanctions biggest life
reality check
North Korea remains the same nuclear
threat it's been as it continues to fire
and test missiles oh and it seems to
have no interest these days I don't know
if you've noticed on having any real
talks aimed at denuclearizing China
boldness push mr. Trump to pressure
China with economic and military threats
Bolton has even suggested using military
force to coerce China to comply military
force mind you it's on the record
Bolton has reported here on this
newscast is also orchestrating the Hong
Kong protests in conjunction with anti
China activists like Jimmy Lai reality
check China and US relations are at an
all-time low China's growing its
military and US workers are paying the
price for the terrorists so there you
have it essentially you know it almost
seems like if it were up to john bolton
our soldiers would be fighting and even
more wars than the seven wars were
already fighting in but what about
mister bolden himself ask yourself would
he send himself to one of these wars
would he be willing to fight in one of
these wars go ahead ask yourself what
did he do when he had a chance to fight
in Vietnam you know what the answer to
that question is by the way and this I
think is telling and certainly
noteworthy and newsworthy here's how he
explains it quote I confess
I had no desire to die in some Southeast
Asian rice paddy I considered the war in
Vietnam already lost see he's referring
to the last years when the
get Nam war was starting to wind down
and he decided it's not worth going but
let me tell you something and this is
really important folks 9,000 Americans
still went to Vietnam during those years
even though it was winding down those
9,000 never made it back they died there
for those soldiers surrender was not an
option
John Bolton says he's tough john bolton
wrote a book recently where he talks
about not going to vietnam you know what
the title of his book is surrender is
not an option
really we're drilling down on the Bolton
firing with Ron Paul and John Jordan
here on the news with Rick Sanchez where
we believe it's time to do news again
[Music]
okay let's get started with our list of
the questions we think you should be
asking tomorrow
why is Bolton out why was he there in
the first place will the world allow
Israel to do a land grab in the West
Bank and man what's that gonna mean and
have scientists actually found a way to
slow down the aging process they seem to
be saying so alright let's get to our a
block right away on this big story that
we're gonna be following for you
fanatically we're spending a large chunk
of our newscast today on this several
weeks ago I got a lot of tips that
President Trump was about to dump John
Bolton I even got a short list of lists
of some replacements that I planned a
report in future shows trust me we're
working on it by the way one of those
who was also privy to the talk that mr.
Trump would soon fire Bolton was none
other than dr. Ron Paul nobody better to
talk to about this topic right away than
Ron Paul in fact let me just State this
unequivocally if there is one person in
this planet who represents the complete
opposite of every single thing that John
Bolton stands for it's Ron Paul
so here dr. Paul I mean take it away the
guy who believes in regime change
everywhere has just lost his job you say
what well I'm not sad that's for sure I
am pleased should have happened a long
time ago I always get you know a little
bit confused when I know that Trump I
believe wants to be less interventionist
why hire some of these people you know
even Pompeo but it's interesting that
Pompeo and bolton thing they weren't
close allies you know personality-wise I
don't believe but they are they were
both interventionists and they were neo
cons we consider them the cons so we
just don't know you know if if Pompeo
has something to say about it he might
be looking for somebody
he knows that he thinks he can get along
better than he did with Bolton but if
he's looking for somebody if he listens
to Senator Rand Paul and Trump does at
least talk to him I don't think that
that's what would happen he'd probably
you know lean toward more well some of
us believe he actually believes you know
I I think he really would like to have
less war but then it then it always met
trouble and it was always bone that
showed up at the last minute to cancel
something out I mean that was it was
almost like he was sent do that well
anybody who cares about peace should be
glad he's not going to be around it's
interesting I mean we could talk about
regime change for example these are the
places just off top my head where I know
that Bolton has been interested in
regime change right of some kind or
another Iran Syria Libya Venezuela Cuban
Yemen North Korea and of course he tried
regime change in Iraq and that has been
an unmitigated disaster to which to this
day he still says it was a good policy
what do you say to a guy like that well
there's not much you can say I don't
think he I think he's obsessed with it I
think he's persuasive you know I always
want to talk to people and persuade them
but you know you've just said in a
different tone that's sort of what
happened you know with a Hillary Clinton
with Obama we need to sign for Assad to
go you know so it's the tone that seems
that does these people in and it sets
the stage for it but you know when you
look at it unfortunately those of us who
believe in less intervention and and if
there's going to be regime change the
people who regime it is they get to
decide not some outsider and I consider
ourselves so much of an outsider and
that we don't have the right to go in
there but unfortunately the foreign
policy is bipartisan and that's why
sometimes we have to be very careful and
saying well you know the
the Democrats you know traditionally in
the past they've been considered to be a
little less hawkish but right now not
anymore
if the Democrats guy with the Democrats
got in they are a lot more hawkish and
Trump is when it comes to Russia why
should we pick a fight with Russia yeah
I think those of us who remember the
Cold War very well we're sort of glad we
don't have a Cold War getting ready for
a hot war and so it's it's a bipartisan
foreign policy that we have to contend
with let me ask you a question that has
come to my mind lately a lot how is it
dr. Paul that's a big picture question
how is it that we as Americans can be
generally altruistic we care about our
fellow man we care about each other I
don't think we're mean I don't think we
intend to go around taking things from
people or starting wars with people yet
our leaders the people we end up
representing us and doing things in our
name
many of them are psychopaths how does
this happen in this country and how we
stop it from happening well if it were
an easy answer we would have it by now
but I I think it has a lot to do I think
your assessment of the American people I
always argue how many 18 year-olds go
around trying to start a war to fight
some 18 year olds 6,000 miles away
neither these young people want to fight
these war and I worked very closely and
you Rico I'm sure that I tried
desperately to try to convince people
don't go to war in Iraq you know it was
a it was a bad thing but our argument
wasn't some well there were two are you
know it was it was the security people
you know intelligence people who wanted
fed who fed Congress lies so they were
controlled by the staffers but it was
also the media because early on and I'm
sure you recall this the early on when
they talked about it the large majority
of American people did not want to go to
war and then it was propaganda
you know it was you had to turn the
enemy into a Hitler and Saddam Hussein
you know he harbored the al-qaeda this
was all based on line but they're fed
into it so the people are overwhelmed I
think their instincts are what you say
but they let their guard down and the
propaganda you know overwhelmed right
now and I think you lean a little bit in
this direction that it's healthy that
American people are now becoming
skeptical yes stuff on the media and I
guess we can give Trump a little bit of
credit for watching out for fake news
and I think that's good
well said yeah I think would you combine
the military-industrial complex with the
Intel community and then you put that
trump card if I can say that which is
the media to bolster their arguments
it's what leads to people like John
Bolton having a position like national
security adviser well said sir my thanks
to you as usual dr. Ron Paul my guest
here on the news with Rick Sanchez thank
you let's go to our other guests now
naval intelligence officer John Jordan I
know he's primed for this conversation
this fellow's been talking about this
for three months now first to come on
this show and essentially tear john
bolton knew backside john take it away
you're on fire today Rick this is this
is your day I think this is America's
day too in a lot of ways I've never been
a fan of John Bolton as you know I don't
agree with everything you said in the
previous segment America does have
enemies out there to do have to be
confronted forcefully the Iraq debacle
should disqualify any policy holder from
ever having in a position in the
executive branch ever again
the thing to look forward to your john
bolton was kind of a vain guy in a lot
of ways you're going to see him you know
in the on the talk show circuits you
know in the Twitterverse trying to
rehabilitate himself in shape
perceptions of himself for book deals
and potential you know Matt you never
know he may well think he's gonna run
for president himself someday so just
just look for that but America does have
enemies out there and sometimes they do
have to be confronted forcefully so
sorry is little more nuance of that but
really went wrong here Rick was there
different approaches to Afghanistan
President Trump wanted to set a calendar
and build the negotiations with the
Taliban against a withdrawal date John
Bolton wanted to make it conditions
basic oddly enough I actually think John
Bolton had the better end of this
argument you can't say we're gonna lead
leave on this date and expect to have
any leverage so in a weird twist of fate
I think the John Bolton had the better
part of that argument but overall it's
probably best that he's gone you can be
tough without undermining your president
and also you can be tough without being
a jerk and I think to a certain extent
he was not able to pull that off
although and here's where the John
Jordan argument comes in it was actually
the left who qualified this guy to be
there with their big push for the Intel
guys and all the other people that they
seem to think we're telling Trump what
to do because they hated Trump am i
wrong absolutely not one little fact
you've already remember when John bolt
was knotted to be ambassador to the
United Nations
he couldn't even be confirmed by a
republican-controlled Senate with a
Republican present hmm maybe that tells
us something about what happens next who
do you think mr. Trump is going to look
to to replace John Bolton what are the
what kind of person are we looking for
John I'm hoping that this time we're
getting somebody who comes from inside
the national carry establishment who
isn't kind of a showboat like an HR
McMasters who writes a rights books and
who's on the lecture circuit or a John
Bolton who's the quintessential showboat
hoping we get someone who's kind of a
steady Eddy thoughtful guy who doesn't
have broader ambitions and doesn't want
to wind up on the lecture circuit the
book circuit and so forth yeah just
somebody who's just gonna quietly go
about his job sometimes there's nothing
wrong with just being a policy wonk
well said thanks John Jordan it is an
interesting day and I'm glad we had you
here to take us through it my friend as
discussed in the previous segment there
are a few people more hawkish than John
Bolton in fact only one comes to mind
and that's his Raley Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu just this year mr.
Netanyahu has continued his now 8-year
old mission to start a war with Iran
he's bomb Syria bombed Iraq bombed
Lebanon and of course he's also
continued to wreak
havoc on the Palestinian territories and
just today mr. Netanyahu dropped another
bomb telling voters that if they vote
for him he will take over a huge swath
of the West Bank and the land grab that
promises to be extremely controversial
in fact here's a little map I could show
you see that map right there shows you
just how big a deal this is it's the
West Bank if you notice it's by far the
largest of the two Palestinian
territories and an orange right there
you'll see the part of the West Bank
that mr. Netanyahu is pledging to annex
it comes out to about a third of the
existing territory so that makes this a
very important story which is why we're
playing it as number two tonight on
Rick's List former Pentagon official
Michel Maloof is joining us now by the
way I kind of want to read to you what
they're saying there they're writing and
saying even in Israel today they're
saying this means the dismantling of the
peace process and essentially
pronouncing there will be no future
Palestine are they right yes of course
this is West Bank was supposed to be
part of the - - the second the
Palestinian state what's going on here
well he's basically wanting to annex the
settlements that that he's allowed to go
into the West Bank over time so and and
you're and he's also trying to appeal to
the more extreme right-wing element
because of as a build-up to elections no
I think he made that comment before he
learned about John Bolton being fired
really I think John Bolton somehow is oh
I think he's very much involved in all
this because okay let me help you here
Bolton and Netanyahu are very tight
they're very tight okay and that is and
that is what probably helped bring his
allow for his calm down
because every time you Bolton Bolton
really every time Trump would say I want
to have a negotiation with the Iranians
for example he'd then get go go back to
Netanyahu and and and conspire to the
basically bucks in the president so wait
a minute you're saying that you have
reason to believe that mr. Bolton was
going behind mr. Trump's back and
working his fidelity more to mr.
Netanyahu that his own he went
that office with his own agenda as a
national security adviser he did
something that no other national
security adviser has ever done is bring
his own foreign policy agenda to the
table so you're saying he was like BB he
was B B's man in the White House exactly
right my god like if that is true I
could imagine look at the timing right
look at the time into the firing seven
days before they'd be B election
re-election right I think Trump is also
sending a message to Netanyahu but but
Trump is is a Netanyahu guide to but not
to the point of that he's going to about
ready to go Bolton almost had him within
ten minutes of bombing Iran if you'll
recall very recently after the shoot
down you know you made a point about
this being a political move by him is
this analogous dare I say to Trump's
wall like Trump thought I can get
elected if I come across very anti
Mexican which he did fairly put I think
he's basically using instead of Mexicans
as his political shill he's using the
Palestinians
well that work no no because this has
been going on for ever and ever
Trump's approach has always been first
of all be bombastic in order to
establish leverage and then negotiate
somewhere you we've seen it time and
again with with respect to North Korea
if left up to Bolton Bolton would have
invaded he would have bombed them and he
wants nothing to do with the
Palestinians just says he wants nothing
to do he last year at a a meek a
terrorist group in Albania it was Bolton
who announced that he would see them in
in Tehran next year but let's put this
in political light right yes I'm the
president and I think this guy is gonna
beat me I think I can be defeated right
now because of my scandalous corruption
deals that everybody knows about but the
one way I could stay in power is if I
can convince the Israeli people I'm the
only one who's gonna protect you against
all those bad guys coming to kill you
well are the Israeli voters that
billable well I think they're they in in
one sense he's trying to appear to be
tough because he has
been accused of being weak in the past
yeah however we saw where he he was
restrained toward Hezbollah and that was
a signal because Hezbollah has had
enough and if he had launched against a
Lebanon it would have been all okay I'm
glad you went there final question what
happens when if if and when he does this
what will be the reaction in the Middle
East so it would be an explosion
seriously oh yeah yeah there you will
have everybody will unite against him
I mean it's and and he doesn't doesn't
have the u.s. backing him to the point
that he was given the assurance that he
would have and I think that if you're
gonna go out and instigate trouble like
this this is problem this weekend I was
reading a book by a hoot Barak where he
warns that we should not overplay our us
speaking of from the Israeli perspective
the Israelis should not overplay their
US backing and the hours don't put the
u.s. in a bad situation like this what
is he doing that yet he has as with the
help of Bolton that's why Trump got rid
of Bolton and I think he's sending a
message at the same time to Netanyahu is
that what you think might end up
happening in this case yes I think I
think he's calling for restraint by
Netanyahu fantastic stuff great
conversation as usual thank you Michael
thank you